لا يكفي مدى هذه الاسلحه لضرب الخطوط
الخلفيه البعيده للقوات الروسيه ولذلك ظلت
اوكرانيا تلح على الدول الغربيه لمدها
باسلحه ذات مدى بعيد
هذه دبابات التي وافقت المانيا على مد
اوكرانيا بها بعد موافقه واشنطن على تقديم
دبابات ابرامز حتى الان وافقت بدين على
تسليم اربعه عشره منها لكنها تشترط الا
تستهدف الاسلحه الجديده الاراضي الروسيه
في حوار مع مجله برد قال المستشار
الالماني اولى ان هناك اجماعا بين الدول
الغربيه على ان استخدام الاسلحه التي
ستقدمها سيقتصر على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لتفادي تصعيد الحرب يدرك الاوكرانيون ان
ما يقوله شورتس شرط لتقديم الاسلحه
الجديده ولذلك سعى وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
لطمانه الجميع
اخبرنا شركائنا اننا ملتزمون بعدم استخدام
الاسلحه التي نتلقاها الاستهداف الاراضي
الروسيه وان استخدامها سيقتصر على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المحتله مؤقتا بهدف تحريرها
تعاهدت الولايات المتحده بمساعدات عسكريه
جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه مليارين ومئتين
مليون دولار الجديد في هذه المساعدات انها
تضم اسلحه متطوره بعيده المدى ومنها
قاذفات جي ال اس دي بي التي يبلغ مداها
150 كيلومترا اي ما يقارب ضعف
التي قدمتها في يونيو الماضي يقول
الاوكرانيون ان روسيا تعلموا من اخطائهم
وصاروا يضعون ذا خائرهم على بعد ثمانين
الى 120 كيلومترا من خط الجبهه لتفادي
ضربات هاي مارس
مع الاسلحه الجديده ستصبح كل القوات
الروسيه داخل المناطق التي ضمتها في
اوكرانيا بما في ذلك شمال شبه جزيره القرم
في مرمى القوات الاوكرانيه من وجهه نظر
روسيا كل الاقاليم الاوكرانيه التي ضمتها
اصبحت اراضيه روسيه ولذلك فهي تنظر الى
تسليمها للاسلحه لاوكرانيا كاعتداء عليها
المتحدث باسم الكريم
قال ان تسليم كييف اسلحه يصل مداها الى
150 كيلومترا سيؤدي الى تصعيد الحرب كل
المؤشرات تقول ان التصعيد قادم وان الغرب
بتقديمه اسلحه لاوكرانيا كان يتردد في
تقديمها دخل في حرب استنزاف مع روسيا